hello in this video we'll talk about
elastin
elastin is one of the fibrous protein
found in extracellular matrix abundantly
it is found in
skin and connective tissues apart from
collagen elastin
is the second most important component
of the extracellular matrix
and you can see the overall distribution
of the elastic it's quite fibrous
in appearance right now imagine
that you have pulled your skin of your
hand and
you would see that after you lift
leave it it would be in shape right
and this is due to the property of
elastin
so the skin behave in an elastic
manner because there is elastin which
can resist in any kind of
mechanical distortions if we didn't have
elastin think about what would have
happened
so elastin helps to maintain the skin
or other kind of tissues such as lungs
which need to relax or expand
it helps to maintain the structural
integrity
so relax so elastin have a relaxed state
and it can be stretched to several
different
conformation so elastin
is pretty much like a spring when
deformative force are applied on that
there could be deformation in this
spring
but eventually it would be restored
so elastin is very important in terms of
structural
and mechanical aspect probably
the loss of elastin fibers is one of the
cause of
wrinkling and aging
in human elastin is encoded by the eln
gene which is a pretty big gene and the
elastin
is now translated and
modified in the endoplasmic reticulum
unlike collagen elastin does not undergo
heavily glycosylation
now elastin majorly have glycine and
proline residues
apart from that it has also lysine which
forms crosslink
unlike collagen it is not glycosylated
and it has very few hydroxy polyprolines
and almost
no hydroxyl lysines the four
lysine groups in the elastin sometimes
combine to form
a pyrimidium nucleus which
is also giving the elastic
property it is called desmosine actually
so lysine oxide oxidase is the key
enzyme which help to form these kind of
structures so let us review the whole
process of
synthesis and secretion of collagen so
it would be encoded by the gene in the
nucleus
processed in the cytoplasm then moved
into endoplasmic reticulum
and following the cell secretory pathway
the
tropoelasting is secreted now
outside the cell there would be lysine
oxidase
which can form crosslinking between
these proper elastins
and ultimately elastin use a scaffold of
fibrilline
and ultimately grow into elastic fibers
and this is how we see elastin in our
tissues or in our connective tissues
so i hope this video was informative if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up
but before that let me tell you there
are some conditions
which is called as elastosis elastosis
means that buildup of elastin in our
tissue excessive buildup of elastin
is also bad not having elastin is bad
but excessive elastin is also bad
and sometime it happens after prolonged
solar exposure
so it is called solar elastosis so
i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
you can uh access my videos in an
academy by using my code a p10 you can
get a 10 percent discount thank you
you